joining us now more fox news contributor
former congressman prosecutor that never
lost a single case in his life trey
Gowdy is with us
let's get your analysis of what the
professor said the constitutional
aspects of this and I do believe that
the Democrats had to take on this
breathtaking hypocrisy and in terms of
ignoring quid and pro and quo Joe and
zero experience honor and firing the
prosecutor or you don't get the billion
yeah Sean I I disagree with professor
Dershowitz a little bit I don't think it
has to be a crime they're they're
they're like you could sleep all day on
the job is the president that's not a
crime but that is malfeasance in office
what I'm particularly interested in is
what Democrats think makes a prima facie
or a threshold case for being able to
investigate something with Trump it's a
conversation and a dadgum bar that's
enough to watch a FISA probe into
someone with with the Biden's political
in the hill just pronounced that there's
no evidence who's looked into it if it's
going to be looked into it needs to be
by law enforcement
look III love my colleagues in the House
of the Senate but if it's criminal
activity that we are interested in it
needs to be looked into by law
enforcement I have been saying the
continent president has a constitutional
oath you take a sworn oath faithfully
execute the laws of the land there's
enough prima facie evidence about Joe
and hunter to warrant an investigation
by far I'm assuming that John Bolton is
going to say something to the effect
that I heard him say I'm not giving him
the money unless he does a B or C the
four facts though your Khalid former
colleague Jim Jordan they never did
anything and haven't pledged to do
anything they didn't even know and they
never felt any pressure it wouldn't
matter to me but I assume that's where
we'll end up at some point well which is
why out of 250 Republicans in the House
in the Senate exactly one voted with the
dazzling Adam chef I know that political
in the New York Times in the hill and
the Washington Post
thank God that wasn't the jury I know
they
dazzled but the reality is Adam Schiff
all these months of investigating
unlimited access to subpoenas could call
whatever witness you want to call in the
house at a 250 Republicans he converted
exactly one amazing congressman trey
Gowdy former congressman I guess calling
you congressman that would be an insult
you're part of our Fox family glad you
here